okay this is Kirsten Beck Navy SEAL
retired let me give you a few tips if
you ever get into a bar fight
tip number one is you want to get some
distance here don't do this to cruddy
chopping kicks you don't want to do that
because the kids don't really work
here's another very important tip don't
hit anybody on a half of the beer bottle
is you can end up in jail it's deadly
weapon not cool
you're in a bar and it's super crowded
and we're bumping in everybody and
starts getting getting really bad with
the tough guys they're gonna clench up
and look how big and you like this right
but then actually I feel punch he's got
to be loose gonna be limber so for me I
don't wanna do is do like this when we
have a little bit higher like this open
hands I'm gonna give up at you can go
back real fast so real tight like that
slow big guy but for me whack whack
right Wow okay Oh your box BAM it's guys
down so this is Kirsten back reminding
you don't get into fights get away from
the situation and be aware later